foreign
Hi how are you good I'm feeling extra
singing today I'm sorry I know it's
annoying what's up
not much
this work
well
overjoyed oh no I actually loved my job
all right cool so what's up
um so I don't remember exactly what I
said on that email but um well I don't
have any idea because I don't see it so
you tell me
um I feel like I just cannot keep
friendships like whatever I do in my
life like
yes I can get friends and I'm surrounded
by people and whatever but I just feel
like anyone I get close to all of a
sudden like I lose that friend and I'm
just like I can never keep a friendship
is there it sounds like you've done some
deep digging just to try to figure this
out when you look back and you say like
you get really close to somebody and
then the friendship just goes away
what's a common denominator if you look
back do they tell you you're too intense
do they tell you you don't show up they
just don't like you do you have bad
breath like why why do they end up why
do these friendships end up fading out
oh no I've never talked to people about
it like but you know though I mean
you're smart
oh no
like I don't know
the reasoning behind it but from how I
see it like yeah
I get close to someone and then like I'm
like oh no they don't actually like me
they don't want to hang out with me they
don't want to be friends with me they're
just being nice to me and whatever and
then I kind of drift away because like
then I'm like okay if I like
distance myself from them maybe they'll
come chasing after me like
they still want to be like they will
come chasing after me because they want
to be friends with me and that just like
and you create a selfie you create a
self-fulfilling prophecy here
yeah you hang out with people you'll
have fun they like you and then you
that little inner machine kicks up
then you decide to put them on trial
decide to test them
and you create the parameters for that
test they will only be my real friend if
I distance myself for them if I leave
them and they come running for me
and people want to honor you if you run
away
I can't imagine the wake of people who
are like I don't know dude Gene's
awesome she just disappeared
yeah
so I just where does where does hold on
where does that voice come from somebody
told you a long time ago that you're not
worth being friends with
who taught you that
not anyone that I know of just myself no
it comes from somewhere
because innately like our our we are
biologically wired to be with other
people
like that's our that's our event
something has to happen whether it's a
mom that didn't show up or a dad that
disappears or a parents who tell coach
or an assault whatever happens something
happens that causes a fracture either
acutely like there's a big blow up or it
happens over time it teaches your body
the world would be better if you were
just over here
I don't know I don't remember anyone
just telling me no very few people say I
don't want to be your friend I want you
to get away from me
they just look at their phone more than
they look at you
they just choose to work 20 hours a day
instead of be with their daughter
they sexually abused him like there's
it's usually not a direct thing
but you can't think of any
no you have a great relationship with
your folks
um
like it's not great but I still love
them and they're my parents and why
isn't it great
growing up
tell me about that
my parents have been married for 33
years but like I guess more than 33
years
but anyways like they've always been
like at each other's throats and they
like it was non-stop bickering and
whatever and I have 11 other siblings
like God Almighty lead with that Genie
gosh
it sounds like you grew up in chaos
yeah but I love my family like of course
you do I'm not I'm not trying to say
they're bad I'm not trying to say
anything negative about them
I'm just trying to give you a road map
back as to somehow
what what age order are you in that 11.
I'm Ace you're eight yeah okay
so all right I'm ninth there's no older
than me so you're down there at the
bottom okay
um
for any number of reasons and you and I
could probably unfold this like untangle
it and not take longer than this call
you've come to believe a story that
people don't want to be around you they
don't like you you're not worthy of
their time other people are more
important than you
which then tells your body that other
people are not safe
and when you begin to violate your
body's understanding of other people
aren't safe when you start hanging out
inside the bear cage at the zoo
your body will get your attention
and sometimes people have to drink in
order to be in in proximity of other
folks or to have intimate relationships
some people have to be super adventurous
and busy
some people are pathologically
analytical
you create stories about why they don't
like you and then you create scenarios
that will make your story inevitably
come true
correct so you ask me how do I make good
friendships
um
you have to decide that I am worth
getting hurt
and before I run out and leave somebody
who's actively hanging out with me and
answering my calls and going and doing
fun stuff together
I'm going to push through that when I
feel my body starting to make these
tests and pull away I am going to
actively lean back in and do something
counteractive here's what that looks
like in my life here's just a simple
example I think I've told this on the
show before
um after a long week of doing media and
doing shows and being on the road and
traveling I get home and I get real real
introverted real fast
like a turtle okay yeah and I know
that's not good for me because from that
I start my diet goes to cry I just have
a whole bunch of numbing behaviors that
I get into so of a rule if somebody
reaches out to me and says for instance
hey we're all getting together on
Saturday night to watch the fights and I
just got home
and my first thought is I just want to
go to bed
I have to go I have to go
have to go there is no there is no ifs
ands or buts I have to go
and I always go and I've never one time
regretted going
but that's just a rule I put in for
myself
that even when I'm tired if I get
invited out I'm gonna go now that's not
for everybody because some people go out
all the time all the time all the time
and they burn themselves to the ground
that's not my issue
those people need to have the courage to
put up a boundary and say I need to rest
but that's not you
when you feel your body go they just
they just ah they probably just or you
text them and it takes them 10 minutes
to text you back instead of five and you
start cranking up stories in your head
right
yeah yeah
right when that happens just go ah maybe
they have diarrhea
yeah maybe they have to go to the
bathroom so bad there's a long line
somewhere
let reality play out before you or as
brene Brown says stop dress rehearsing
tragedy
stop Imagining the worst case scenario
my gut tells me you're pretty fun to
hang out with is that fair
oh no I I used to be the center of
attention and just like
be like going everywhere anytime just
like center of attention and a loud
obnoxious person and then if years ago
where did she go
I lost her where
my mom knew I had depression before
years before I realized it and it took
one night
I just feeling so bad and I just wanted
to die now that night I called a friend
and me
I decided to finally go get help and
then
and then
like I struggled
for years and then one one night I was
like absolutely could not handle it
anymore
and I was
about to just overdose I heard the pills
in my hand I was just
holding it shaking it just couldn't
handle it anymore
I'm like okay I'm just gonna go to bed
and see what tomorrow brings
and
um I'm gonna just go to bed and see what
tomorrow brings and then
my friend the next day asked me
how long have you been doing and I told
her and then she got scared she knew
I've been struggling
she I told her and she got scared so she
told my mom and her mom told my mom
and my mom picked me up from work and
brought me to the mental hospital
and like that was in March of last year
and then
I struggled for a whole nother year and
then
like right after she brought me to the
mental hospital I was so mad at her
like why did you have to put me in that
place I do not want to be there I don't
want to
whatever and I was so mad at her that I
ended up
ditching her
and then
like a year of struggling and I would
just became so in through
so Within Myself never going anywhere
and
then this year
I was working and somebody I've known
for years but she started working here
and then we just became so close so fast
you know I literally was loving myself
loving my life and life got busy and it
felt like she was way too busy to be
friends with me and I was just like
getting
so
like does she even like me does she even
want to be friends with me and just like
getting in my head and then right now
like
we see each other at work and say hi and
smile but that's just about it and I
don't know what like
I don't know how to do this all right
let me back out number one thank you for
telling me that
number two
I'm glad you're still here
number three
you can get mad at me and hang up too
but your mom did the exact 100 right
thing I would have done the exact same
thing for my two kids
hold on
of course you did I know you hated it
there those are scary scary places I've
been there too much they're terrifying
okay
and you're still here
yeah
and any parent any day of the week would
rather their kid be mad at them in a
hospital than planning a funeral
yeah okay so you can get mad at me too
but your mom did the right thing
I know okay number three
you're gonna have to decide
not to not be depressed that's insane
anyone who tells you that just cut them
off you don't be friends with that
person because they're a [__]
yeah but you're gonna have to decide
you're worth feeling better than you
feel
you're gonna have to get with a
professional not back at the psych ward
unless you're gonna hurt yourself again
but
with a counselor who can give you some
new skills
because
you have one I have a therapist yeah but
in your case I think there needs to be a
lot less talking and a lot more making
plans and practicing
yeah
you are
um the baseball player that used to hit
home runs all the time and just is
flinching when the ball comes now
that home run hitter is still in there
things just got blurry
is that fair
sometimes we have to practice those
things that we used to do that made us
feel good even we don't feel like doing
those things
and in your case um I've said this on
the show a bunch before
um feelings our feelings job is not to
um tell us the truth our feelings job is
to Keep Us Alive
and sometimes our feelings don't tell us
the truth
so if reality says if if all of the
external things are this person's
calling me back she's hilarious she
wants to have fun all the time she's
doing all this cool stuff and she's
really busy that's awesome
I feel like she's pulling away from me
doesn't want to be my friend and she
hates me
I think objectively you could go I'm
gonna write that feeling down and I'm
going to examine that feeling is that
feeling telling me the truth
no it's not
is she really busy yeah of course am I
busy yeah of course
but when we get together do the wheels
come off because we have so much fun yup
and when I say doing the work what I
mean is practicing over a period of a
few months
I'm gonna challenge those feelings but
my feelings tell me to shut it down when
my feelings tell me to avoid answering
the phone with my feelings telling my
mom hates me when my feelings tell me
I'm so mad at so and so I'm gonna write
that down in a journal and I'm gonna I'm
gonna call it out are you telling me the
truth
and all of those I write down I'm going
to tell my counselor here's what I wrote
down here's the feelings I wrote down we
go through them with me is that true is
that true a couple of them will be true
my friend got really busy she got a big
promotion
so instead of making it all about how
she's not done enough time for me it's
dude I get to celebrate my friend it's
amazing
and on and on and on here's the big
thing I want to pass along to you
your happiness and your joy
and your life
um Essence Force whatever it is I don't
know how to say without saying it
sounded cheesy
it's not out there it's in you
it isn't something that you can go get
like I finally found a friend and then I
was the happiest I've ever been no no no
it comes from the inside out
I finally believed I was worth having
fun and I finally started putting myself
out in positions because I love dancing
I'm going dancing
and then I started meeting friends
and the body lit up like a Christmas
tree because it was awesome
but somehow a couple years ago and it
could be chemical it could be life
circumstances it could be a loss that we
haven't talked about could be any number
of things
you flip your body flipped that inverted
the switch from outgoing fun silly
goofball Gene to
Zoom live in the feelings live in the
feelings living the feelings feelings
become my entire ecosystem my entire
world
and it's just a choice to work with a
professional to say I'm not going to
live in feelings anymore I'm going to
identify them I'm gonna feel them but
then I'm gonna go do the next thing that
I know is gonna help me be healthy and
over time your body will the sun will
come back out
I promise it will if you stay stay in on
it
promise it will if you stay in on it
so how do you make good like how do you
not overthink your friendships how do
you know if they're good friends or not
let the truth be what the truth is
and when the truth gets cloudy with how
you feel and how you're emotional you
are write those things down
and say is this matching up with reality
I feel like this person hates me but
they've returned my calls every time
this week we've hung out twice last week
we're hanging out again this weekend
Okay so objectively
they don't
my body's just trying to get my
attention for some weird reason hey
buddy we're good I'm driving this car
now we're good
foreign